brought to you by Bioshock the
collection it's that time again for the
latest 10 video game releases and we're
tipping off with NBA 2k 17 the annual
number one best-selling basketball video
game is back and it's bringing new
features with it there's the advanced
shooting scale that gives you complete
control over the power and aim of your
ball and for the first time in the
franchise there's college integration
where you get to play as college
basketball player legends the my league
feature allows for much customization
letting you choose teams logos uniforms
and also lets you share them with the
NBA 2k community you can shoot them
threes September 20th killer instinct
originally released in 2013 since then
the game has released three seasons
worth of content if you're into fighting
games well now might be the time to hop
on board killer instinct definitive
edition brings you everything you need
that means all three seasons all 26
characters including the special guests
like arbiter from Halo rash from
Battletoads and general RAAM from peers
of war you also get 20 stages with their
visual upgrades every song in the ki
library never-before-seen concept art
and behind-the-scenes videos all for
forty dollars you'll be able to finish
those ultimate combos September 20th the
year is 2038 and the city of tokyo lies
in ruins in shin megami tensei for
apocalypse you'll find yourself reliving
the same events and characters from shin
megami tensei for a neutral path only
from a different perspective our story
takes place with a young teenager who
was killed on a demon hunt in exchange
for his life back he must serve as dog
does godslayer with demonic powers you
set forth meeting new and familiar faces
while also recruiting demons to help you
survive the post-apocalyptic Tokyo
choose peace or unleash anarchy
September 20th
you are called upon once again guardian
destinies fourth expansion the rise of
iron comes out the enemy race the Fallen
have breached the wall that surrounds
old Russia and I've acquired the ancient
play called Siva this nanotech virus has
been protected for many years by the
iron Lords you must rise to the throne
and take back fell winters peak and set
out to become the new generation of iron
Lords other than a new story campaign
and quests players will be getting new
armor and gear weapons a new raid and
strike news own enemies crucible maps
and modes and much much more you can
become a lord iron Guardian September
20th and that's it for the week do
remember that release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change thanks for watching take care now